في تونس تعقد بمقر مجلس نواب الشعب ببردو
اولى جلسات البرلمان الجديد حيث من
المنتظر انتخابه رئيس جديد للبرلمان
وانتخابه اعضاء لجنه النظام الداخلي ويراس
الجلسه العمل الافتتاحيه للمجلس اكبر
الاعضاء سنا وكانت الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات قد اعلنت في الخامس والعشرين
من فبراير المنقضيه عن القائمه النهائيه
للاعضاء الجدد للبرلمان
وعددهم
154 نائبا ويمثل انتخاب اعضاء البرلمان
الجديد اخر المحطات ضمن خارطه الطريق التي
كان اعلنها الرئيس سعيد وتضمنت استشاره
الكترونيه واستفتاء شعبيا على تنقيح
الدستور
وتنظيما انتخابات تشريعيه مبكره
لو عبرت كتله حركه النهضه في البرلمان
التونسيه المنحل عن عدم اعترافها
بالبرلمان الجديد
وتمسكها بدستور 2014 كمصدر وحيدا للشرعيه
وجددت الكتله في بيان رفضها لما وصفتها
بالقرارات الاحاديه الجانب التي تنتاجها
سلطه الامر الواقع ودعت كل التنظيمات الى
مزيد من النظام السلمي من اجل عوده
الشرعيه كما دعت الانتخاب انتخابات
الرئاسيه
وتشريعيه مبكره